(whooshing)
(basketball dropping)
- Good morning, Believe
Nation, today we're going to
talk about how to
increase your will power.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you like the best.
As always, guys, as
you're watching the clips,
if you hear somebody say
something that really
resonates with you, please
leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well.
Also when you write it
down, it's much more
likely to stick with yourself too, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Michael Angelo's really a great
story on will power and self control.
He was beaten severely
when he was a young kid
by his father, his father
wanted him to be, to pursue
a more noble profession, a
more lucrative profession.
And Michael Angelo
wanted to be a sculptor.
And his father beat him
and his father tried to
get him off course and
Michael Angelo said no.
I want to be a sculptor
and finally through his
grit and perseverance
and unrelenting-ness,
Michael Angelo's father said,
ya know what, okay, fine,
you're 14 years old, I'm
going to allow you to go to
apprentice with a Florentine Master
and he will help you become a sculptor.
And Michael Angelo moved to Florence
and he started to study.
And he started to practice
and again, this is a story
of self discipline and
world class will power.
And through his mastery
and through his practice
and through his suffering
and through his persistence
and through his focus, all
of these great lost traits
that are no longer celebrated
in this world where
all too often, people are card carrying
members of the Cult of Mediocrity.
Through this practice,
through this devotion,
he became well known, he
became known far and wide.
He created the beautiful sculptor David.
If you go to Museum of
Academia in Florence,
you'll see David, you'll see
some of his other masterpieces.
And part of that whole
region started to honor
the way that Michael Angelo was
appearing and performing as a sculptor.
Because of his mastery, a
lot of the other artists
like Raphael and the
Renaissance Patriots became,
they became jealous and
so they devised a very
elaborate and interesting
plan to discredit
and to ridicule Michael Angelo.
And Michael Angelo's
peers went to the Pope
who what Julis II and
they said to the Pope,
why don't you get Michael Angelo
to paint the Sistine Chapel?
And the Pope said sounds good.
And so the Pope went
over the Michael Angelo
and said, I want you to
restore the greatness of Rome.
And the greatness of Rome
is now on your shoulders
because I want you to
pain the Sistine Chapel.
And I want you to make it
a masterpiece that holds
the world in awe when they see it.
And Michael Angelo replied to the Pope.
He said, ya know, I'm not a painter.
And I've never painted, I'm a sculptor.
But Julius the II was very persistent
and eventually Michael Angelo said fine,
I'm going to agree and over
four years, four hard years,
four years that took
incredible self control,
incredible grit, we're going
to talk about grit in this
webinar, incredible focus,
incredible discipline.
Michael Angelo created the Sistine Chapel.
Now let's put this into perspective.
I mean, Michael Angelo had
never painted Fresco before.
Michael Angelo had to paint
something on the ceiling
of the Sistine Chapel that
people standing many feet
below could look up at
and see with great detail.
Michael Angelo dealt with
the fact that the painting
on the Sistine Chapel was moldy.
There were paint issues, he
had to deal with the fact that
the Pope was very ill and he
thought he might not get paid.
He actually developed this
incredible elaborate system
of scaffolding which allowed
him to back backwards
for four years on the
Sistine Chapel and he damaged
his back in the process
but he did it for the art.
He did it for the discipline,
he did it for what it made of
him, he did it for his
commitment because the great
artists and the great performers
are much less about ego
and applause and money and
they do their work for what
it makes of them as human beings.
And after four years,
Michael Angelo's eyesight
was so damaged from
looking at the images on
the Sistine Chapel that he
suffered permanent eye damage.
But like I said, once he
was finished, the world
was awe struck at what he created.
And now 20 million people
a year go to the Vatican
and they do experience
this breath taking work
of artistry and human
ingenuity constructed by
an ordinary man who exercised world
class will power named Michael Angelo.
And so ladies and gentlemen,
I guess what I'm suggesting
to you is one of the fundamental points.
The myth of the talented
genius, the myth of the gifted
genius is nothing more than
a lie society has sold you.
I don't know if I expressed
that clearly but what I'm
trying to suggest to you
is the world says, the
Michael Angelo's and the
Beckham's and the Jay Z's
and the, the great
entrepreneurs, the Carlos Slim's,
the Warren Buffet's, the
Jack Dorsey's, you know,
the founder of Twitter, the Jeff Bezos,
the founder of Amazon, the Mozart's
and the Picasso's and the
Bach's, society teaches us
and trains us that these
people are somehow born
with special talents and
what I'm here to remind you,
a deep respect for all
25,000 or 24,922 on this
webinar from around the
world is that is a lie
that society has sold us to keep us small.
And if you look at the science
and science coming out right
now is indisputable, we're
going to get into that science.
But what science says is
genius is much less about
your genetics and much more about
your self control and your discipline.
Genius is much less about natural talent
and much more about
practice, persistence, focus,
grit, dealing with suffering,
dealing with failure,
dealing with laughter
while the rest of the world
thinks you should stop,
genius is much more about
continuing, practice,
developing your craft.
(upbeat music)
- The first idea is to
emotionally engage with
that dream each morning of your life.
See, a lot of people
don't actually struggle
with the discipline part in
terms of the doing the thing.
It's that they're not getting
revved up to do the thing.
In other words, we got a
problem with motivation,
not necessarily just discipline.
We have a problem with,
that once in a while, you
hit it, you do it, you do the work.
But a lot of times you
fall off because you're
not emotionally engaged in it.
It's like, if you want
a lot of discipline,
you need a high level
of emotional connection
and focus on that thing that
you want to work towards.
So every morning, what
I want you to do is just
start a new visualization practice.
When you wake up in the
morning, close your eyes,
think about the dream,
the aspiration, the thing
that you're really after in
life and just visualize it.
And it really gets yourself
emotionally attached,
emotionally engaged with it.
Think about how great it will
feel for you to have that
thing or be that thing
or contribute that thing,
to make that difference,
just think about it.
Allow it to well up in
your heart a little bit.
Get excited about it, remember the dream.
That's why we get away from
discipline because we're
so busy with the chaos
of the world that we
emotionally are no longer
attached in a way that
our brain says, hey, man, focus on this.
It's important to you, remember?
So if your heart is
disengaged, it's difficult to
stay disciplined so every
morning make it a practice
to actually just imagine
the pay off, the benefit,
the contribution, the
art, the thing that you do
and are doing and do contribute.
If you can do that more
often, you'll be more fired up
and you'll stay back on track.
- Number two, set up hard
and fast rules in your life,
rules that cannot be violated.
'Cause from a willpower
perspective, it is very
draining again, to go back
and forth in your head.
So it's much easier to say,
okay, I will not drink soda
and I'll only eat foods
off of this list than it is
for you to go okay, I
ate really good yesterday
and I worked out extra
hard, now I'm at dinner.
And they just gave me a
free dessert, is it okay
for me to have a small portion?
'Cause that takes a lot of
mental energy to process.
When you set up hard and
fast rules, as draconian
as this might feel and
sound at first, it actually
creates a tremendous amount
of freedom in your own life
to spend your brain power on the
things that matter the most.
So set up rules, you must
work between these hours.
You need to go to the
gym five days a week.
For me, I set up a rule,
I have to release one
YouTube video every single
Monday and that's why I am
here right now so set up rules.
- What's your why, hey,
if I don't give ya'll
nothin' else, you better
start that, what's your why?
You know I do what I do and
I do it so passionately.
'Cause my grandfather was
a high school dropout.
My father was a high school dropout.
I was a high school dropout and
we about to break the cycle.
I do what I do so my son won't have
to go through what I went through.
When I was at the football game,
my old dude wasn't with me.
I saw other kids with their
father, I said that'll
never happen to me, I do what I do because
my daughter says she goin' to Harvard.
It ain't even about ya'll, I'm about
to here and blade ya'll, why?
Because I'm tryin' to
get ya all in the NFL.
I ain't about to miss this opportunity.
This is the first NFL team
I've ever done in my life
and I'm about to lick it, I'm
about to give it everything
I got and I will know if
I don't get another gig,
it won't have nothin'
to do with the fact that
I didn't put everything on the field.
What's your why, why do
you wake up in the morning?
Why do you put on the jersey,
why do you go out and practice, why?
- Your hardest tasks, you
should set for the morning.
In the morning, you typically
have the highest will power.
Your brain is refreshed,
glucose stores are pretty good
even though you've been fasting overnight.
You're refreshed, you're ready to go.
You're more likely to make smart decisions
because you can think, you have clarity.
You're not exhausted by the day yet.
So whatever is hard for you,
whether that's exercise,
some new thing you're
trying to do, try to do it
before your day, before
the long day which is why
most successful people
in history have some kind
of smart morning routine so they wake up,
they do the most important
task first while they're fresh
and then do the rest of the
stuff throughout the day
or at the end of the day
when they're more tired.
- [Narrator] Before you
start to seriously build
your self discipline, the
first thing you're going
to do is learn how to make it easier
on your future self to complete a task.
Think of it as stretching before a run.
Take out your WellCast
Journal and write down
a task that you regularly put off.
Let's say there's a big pile of dishes
that greets you every day after work.
And instead of cleaning them right up,
you bow to the temptation
of collapsing on your couch
and leave them until the
next morning when you tell
yourself, you have time
to take care of them.
So help your future
self out, write down two
things that you're going
to do to make it easier
for you to complete the task the next day.
Stack the dishes neatly
in the sink or scrape the
food off any especially dirty
plates before turning in.
And that brings us to Workout Two.
Now that you've started
stretching your muscles,
let's try a conditioning exercise.
Okay, now the same scenario
greets you when you
return home from work, you're tired.
It's been a long day
and the dirty mountain
of dishes is sitting in your sink.
This time, figure out a way to
break the activity into segments.
Take out your WellCast
Journal and write down
a week's plan for how you're going
to tackle this task gradually.
For example, the first
night, do five dishes.
The second night, do seven,
slowly increase how many you do.
Your discipline will slowly build as well.
Like any exercise,
building up your will power
will take time and effort but you
keep at it, you'll see results.
- If you want to increase
your willpower, you
need to remember your
why, remember the big
game that you are trying to play.
And for me, this is something
that I need to do daily.
I find that no matter how
great a day, it's video day.
It's filming day for me,
I'm pumped, I'm excited.
I leave here feeling amazed and energized.
No matter how great a
day I had, the next day
I start from scratch, the
next day I'm starting over.
The next day I need to
build myself up again
as part of my morning
routine and ritual to remind
myself to push harder,
to do more, to not stop,
to not rest, to not
stay in my comfort zone.
It's a daily battle and
a daily grind and I think
having that morning routine
becomes so so so so important
to help you remember you why.
I think you can only force
yourself to do something
for so long before you quit.
If you don't like the
work that you're doing,
if you're not genuinely
excited about the work
that you're going to do today,
that can only last for so long.
You can only increase you
will power to do something
that you don't want to do
for so long before you quit
and realize, this isn't for me.
I got to move on and do something else.
But it's for the things
that we do want to do.
It's for the big dreams
that we have that sometimes
we don't end up believing in anymore.
We have a down day, we
don't have that big boldness
or that motivation all the time.
Structuring into your
daily routine, the why.
Why's it's so important to
you, why you're going to hold
yourself back, where you know
you're going to fall down.
For me, especially, when
my schedule's thrown
off, that's where I start to fall down.
I'm a pretty scheduled
person and I have different
things on different days and
it really, really, really
works well for me, the
system, the schedule works
amazingly well for me
but on days when there's
interruptions, it's
hard for me to get back
on the schedule for the rest of that day.
The next day starts, new
schedule, great to go.
But if I fall off in
the middle of one day,
it's really hard for me to catch back up
and so it's either, I design
my schedule so that I don't
have interruptions which
I've done for the most part.
But there's still going to
be those five to 10% of days
where something random,
mysterious happens that
you have to adjust and deal with.
And the second way to do it,
that I've been working on
is having a trigger to
get you back on schedule,
having a trigger to get
you back into the zone
of where you want to be
and so what I do is I start
my day with saying a few lines to myself.
I'll say this three times
and if I can't start my day
with it because there's been
some kind of interruption,
then as soon as I'm ready
to start working again,
as soon as I need that extra
little jolt, as soon as
I need to remember my why
and the push and the drive,
then I read it again, ya know
what, let me read it for you.
I'm going to pull it
out, this is what I read.
This is how I start my day
and if I fall off track,
I get back to this, I
read this three times.
Today I will push myself
to be my absolute best,
to believe more, care more and try harder.
I vow not to let
distractions, schedule changes
or fear prevent me from being great.
I will make every minute count
because my time is running out.
I have the ability to change the world
and it's my responsibility to do so.
If you want to increase your
will power, remember you why.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Abilash asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
on the next edition of
Believe Life, leave it down
in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know, what
did you take from this video?
What did you learn the
most, what are you going
to do in your life or
your business to increase
your will power, did I miss
something here that you
want to share, leave it
down in the comments below.
I love to hear from you,
finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out to 2000 Books.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word and posting
that awesome picture
of you outside with it,
I really hope you enjoy
the beautiful weather,
as well as the book.
Thank you so much for your support.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever Your One Word is.
Much love, have an amazing
day and I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(basketball bouncing)
- I think it's your natural
responsibility to be great.
And I think for you not
to do whatever it takes to
learn how to run your
mind like a superstar
and to make this your
absolute best year yet,
I think for you not to
invest in becoming the person
you know you're meant to
be, I think for you to play
small with your life, for
you to go to work and coast,
for you not to do things
that are difficult, for you
not to lean into your
fear, for you not to read,
for you not invest in
your learning, for you not
to populate your life
with people who are better
thinkers than you, is
being out of integrity.
And I think it's being
out of integrity to you,
to your family and to the world.
And really, and I know
mostly we don't talk about
high performance and peak
potential in terms of
integrity but you have a
personal obligation as do I,
to be the best human being
and to express the gifts
and the talents you were born with.
And if you don't do that
because you've fallen into
mediocrity or because you've
bought a bill of goods
that the world has sold
you, that you're average,
that you're average, that
you're ordinary, that the
Beckham's and the Jay
Z's and the Mandella's
are somehow different from you,
well, that's just not true.
And you are breaching your
own integrity and your own
responsibility and if I do the same thing,
I'm equally responsible
because the world is less of a
place and your family is less happy
because you're not living at your best.
And related to that,
will power and expressing
your potential and playing
a genius and creating
a life that's legendary is
actually the secret to happiness.
I went for a little
walk before the webinar
and I thought to myself,
ya know, full expression of
your will power is really
how you express your genius
and how you express the
genius you were born into.
But it's also the secret to happiness.
I mean, we watch Breaking
Bad or we drink too much
or we gossip too much or
we spend too much time
on the internet and we think
we're doing that to keep
us happy and you've read my
books and you've followed
me so you know I believe that victims
love entertainment,
leaders love education.
Ordinary people love
leisure and extraordinary
people invest in their learning.
I mean, I looked at the best of the best.
I look at the billionaires
that I've coached,
NBA players who follow my work,
Taylor Swift reads my books.
FC Barcelona reads The
Monk Who Sold His Ferrari.
John Bon Jovi read The
Monk Who Sold His Ferrari
and I say that simply to share with you.
If you look at the best of the best,
they are the best of
the best in full passion
in excellence and exuberance
because they stretch.
Because they want to be the best
and let's go to the science.
Every time you do something uncomfortable,
every single time you exercise
self control and will power,
you release a neuro
transmitter called dopamine.
Dopamine is the secret to happiness.
Dopamine is the neuro
transmitter of motivation.
And it doesn't happen playing
Grand Theft Auto Live.
It's doesn't happen gossiping
at the water cooler.
It doesn't happen being
addicted to distraction.
Dopamine is released when
you do difficult things,
when you are focused, when
you achieve a small win
and you say yeah, I did it.